ha ha ha ha me I will salute my and
we'll be good hey your fam andaman gb
the farm I didn't a more put in World
War I hire a wet it out ha ha handball
in Leavenworth a 100-foot marroquin
won't be okay when a crime and
[Silence]
Sean McDonough hey I'm not a lothario
got to sit in the chair until a little
while I just want to have you know Maxie
one thing I think there's a new version
of the 99 names of Allah yes how do i
also saw send them in the lightest I
don't notice Venus not sorry when I saw
her and FLL gentleman when I think there
is in you Nelly there's a few of
the names from this you know they
changed a little bit so there's a new
it's the majority are there but
there's only few where changed so maybe
shall we found i will change you see the
rights that other more sense with what
do you think policy child is a michelle
child myself just a couple of hair
and he's having her about you know if
there's a open i'd a buffet or
something and then should we ask the
students or the other first you go first
on how what's the best way of doing it
my loved ones ok so Sean McDonough we
will maybe then I take care of your kids
and shall I tell it to make it tomorrow
love one yes so please yes just a
yoga no it's and please just a reminder
do not waste food please just I can't
lock him just have a look here plz you
shall appear it Roger Kevin still
aziz 11 APR hello bondage would to
Kubelik show outage or I'll fire
more what
well